my goal here and in this lecture is sort
of to give you some ideas why we have
all been doing fancy mathematics from
the day we are born and tell you what
the mathematics is and also a given
indication that that mathematics
actually penetrates all walks of life
now we heard about linguistics just a
minute ago you will see very very
quickly how how this is happening I'll
tell you a little bit about the language
of birds and music and and so on and
you'll see the patterns and the way
you're doing it suddenly you just
figured out this puzzle here by
connecting the the words to the
sentenced and the position of the words
relative to the other words and
basically building an internal
internalizing a network of this little
instances that you have here so my goal
here is actually to tell you what it is
that you have been doing subconsciously
render it conscious so that you can do
it systematically or that the machine
can do it for you okay
so let me tell you about so my goal here
is to tell you about all kinds of
networks in fact you will be convinced
by the end of the hour I hope that
everything around you everything in life
is built up of little networks so here
is a network of Supreme Court as it was
several years ago and what is the
network every judge is a node the net
network and you connect the judges to
each other by the number of votes that
they had a greater number of agreements
that they had in various decisions so
you see that this particular network
well all the Republican appointed judges
are sort of mostly in one cluster
there's some red judges which are in the
other cluster liberals and in the others
and Sandra Day O'Connor is sort of the
bridge tells you a lot about what the
internal structure of the of the court
was at that time in terms of agreements
and disagreements between the various
members of the court so it's a very
simple network I'll explain how this is
done in a variety of other contexts we
will see networks of say characters in
the Shakespeare play a character in the
work of Balzac or network of songs of
music and so on songs of birds and so
and so on so we will see several
examples that I'll give you a few more
so this is social networks and you may
or may not know but Yale has they an
Institute for network science which is
right across the street here and those
are some of the displays they have the
the right network up here is network of
of people and and you see that blue is
indicating that they are somewhat
unhappy so the blue are unhappy people
and yellow are the happier they have a
sunny disposition so you look at this
network and you see immediately
something that sort of birds of a
feather flock together right I mean
people who are unhappy tend to clump I
mean the connection between two people
is that they're friends they know each
other they have their social it's just
and this is just a social network of
people and so two people are linked to
each other in this in this configuration
if if they're if they're friends if they
know each other and you see that here is
a network of blue people we are all
mutual friends the yellow people are
mostly also congregated
together occasionally you have isolated
unhappy people which is normal they
don't talk to anybody and but you could
do that you could also do the same thing
instead of looking at people who are
happy unhappy look at smokers and people
who smoke and don't smoke you'll get
exactly the same sort of configuration
that smokers tend to be friends with
other smokers and non-smokers always
non-smokers one thing that made a lot of
a lot of noise in their observation also
that people who are overweight tend to
be together
and so people suggest same or some
contagion there's no contagion it's just
there's less social stigma among people
of the same kind and so it makes it
easier to be friends so you see the
point here is just this just a display
itself is is potentially quite
informative so the network's you have
seen I mean you all know about Facebook
and in Google and so on so they're two
different networks right Facebook is
mostly a network of social network of
friends in which you exchange
information and you exchange not news in
some sense and and Google is a is an
information network in which you are
looking for objects of interest whether
it's looking for some product you you
want to buy or you're looking for a
document or a text that you want to to
retrieve or to find or maybe find us
find out something about a person so
that different kinds of networks right
and I what I'd like to show you that
they're all sort of the same and not
only that but the underlying mathematics
they serve the the framers the fabric of
the networks which is called a graph in
as a mathematical term is a fabric that
you can weave in various ways depending
on what you need to achieve
and the way you actually work on it is
through processes of inference and
diffusion which I will I will explain so
as you see here there are social
networks there are networks of patient
data for example networks which you can
use for a variety of reason in order to
organize people in terms of their
medical condition or and you can use
that to do to estimate whether there are
at risk or not or whether they should be
taking a certain medication or not
taking a certain medication and so on so
what I'm really saying is that this
issue once you you you put everything in
this context of of network you see that
thing in your life is is around some
networks ok when you are doing looking
at doing this language and linguistics
it's it's a networks of language words
by themselves are not defined unless you
connect them to the to the other words
in the same context so a given word in a
given context as a completely different
meanings at the same word in a in a
different situation so let me give you
some demo here so this is a project that
I was teaching a class of networks last
year and the students in the class had
to have some project in which they build
a network that they particularly are
interested by so here they the project
was this this is the the structure
hermits rush which is I think they the
Vermont State Bird Sings each one of
those nodes here will be a song but
actually a bird doesn't think a single
song at a time it's a composition
usually you write the song for the going
to another one to another one and so on
so let's just look at how this thing
works and so
so just at this point it's just going
around
around here by how how say how they
actually occur what is they what their
importance in some sense but it doesn't
really matter the point is that when you
are at some position like here you have
it
you can skip here or here or some other
places what is it we can listen to it
for half an hour it will never repeat
itself
okay every little song is the same okay
but the composition constantly changes
okay well do it with music in a minute
right but here the point is there are
other aspects to it which the birds have
which is they want a song to be
recognized by somebody else as being
interesting in particular if it's done
for mating then the the way that you you
do the arrangement of the composition is
done to attract others but in this way
what I'm going to show you in a minute
in fact everything we are going to talk
about can be viewed on this particular
thing so if I run it a little bit faster
it'll be maybe more natural but let's
find it it goes on and on you can have
it in a background it's like being in
the woods and that's what this thing is
doing but let me show you the rest of
the report so so basically what is a
story here the story is that each little
song which is one of those one of those
each one of those letters here ABC each
one represent a song and what the errors
represent here is a following thing if
you are at a then you pick a coin you
toss the coin 50% of the time you go
here 50% of the time you go here and you
just toss the coin okay once you are
here let's say
let's actually follow a song so hey so
let's say I toss my coin I went here to
G and now when I'm in G I have various
possibilities with the probability 1/4
of a time I'll go to H 40% of the time
I'll go to C and 25% of the time I will
go to E and as you can see there's some
misses some of the time I'll stop I
won't go anywhere ok so that's why it
doesn't add up to a hundred okay so
basically so what happens is they the
bird things then tosses a coin decides
to go here or there it gets to this
place there's three possibility so it
doesn't toss the coin it's also die
right if it's an even number there are
three possibilities and and I knew it
decides right so what the bird is doing
here is what we randomly in the sense
that you are to give in position your
toss a coin depending how many options
you have you toss a coin with that many
options so with that many sides whatever
comes out is there is a direction that
you go in then you can reach another
position you toss a coin and you keep on
going and that's exactly that's what we
are hearing here so so those numbers
that are here are you can write them in
a table which is what is happening here
which is it's just instead of this
picture it's basically saying that if
you are in a you can go to be with 50%
of the time and 2g8 50% of the time if
you are in be alright
this thing is not particularly okay if
you are out there in B you will go you
will go to a a certain percentage to see
a certain percentage to ietters and to H
percentage so the point is this is what
the bird is doing
okay you can collect this data all you
have to do is count sit down and make up
make a table and count this is how the
table was obtained and that table
completely describes a style of the bird
okay so it doesn't describes the songs
but describes them the way the bird is
actually doing it and characterizes this
particular network that we have here let
me rewrite the network in a slightly
different picture and in this picture
what we are doing is something
remarkable in quite advanced mathematics
okay what you do here is you run this
bird song for a long time some flowers
okay and just count okay how often did I
see G CDE a B I and H you just count and
you your label you you basically draw a
circle around each one of those songs by
by how big it is relative to the others
right so the size of G is the bigger one
because the this particular song occurs
most often and you see G is AC so the
lines connecting G is connected to 2 e
to itself but E is a is a very common
one too it's connected to B and D and so
for really asking yourself once you had
this transition table which tells you
how do you go from one one song to the
next one song to the next if you just
wait a very long time sort of a
distribution of the songs or stable a
stable distribution of the songs which
really doesn't change over time that
sort of a signature and the nice thing
about it that when you look at the more
the ones that occurs most most often
like G here this is sometimes called the
Google rank so if you go to google and
you look for something and you think
that coming in order the order that
they're coming is by how frequent these
things occur and such in subnet
of disgust okay which is a relationship
between the different websites but but
here you see all I've done is nothing
there's no just I mean there's Counting
right all we have done is count okay
we've said we count there are several
objects we count how much and there's
some sort of dynamic change we count how
much you move from here to here from
here to here and so on and that's it but
by the way interrupt me for any any any
any question that just occurs so let me
get out of this and let's do something
else which is an app which is based on
the same is the same principle
so let me take this out so let me
explain here what's going on
so you can take any piece of music we'll
do some other more popular one in a
minute and you can relate
so you organized so this is the
moonlight sonata by Beethoven you are
just organize it in a circle like we did
but the circle is organized by by the
time you play so you start you start at
noon you go all around until you come
back right and now the different links
that you have it's just like the links
we saw a minute ago I'm really linking a
segment of the music to some other
segments somewhere else within this
spark piece of music and I'm now
artificially I'm going to say well I
have when I have two segments one here
and one there which I connect with
pepper similar to each other I allow
myself to skip just like what the birds
were doing okay so I can go from one
this this musical theme to that one and
that one and so on this way I have
variations on this sonata right so I can
generate as many variations as I want
just like the bird was doing the
variation on the different different
songs a minute ago and you have in this
software you actually have a way of
tuning it so you see here I can decide
how often I want to do sayings whether
no I want
let me change tunes anybody want to pick
something well let's take that
so this is the it's a website called the
infinite jukebox and you can just play
with it as much as you want you can tune
it to whatever you your favorite way of
doing it is
it doesn't
it doesn't jump for some reason with me
to say jumped over there and jumped over
there starting to jump around I reset
the parameter
sometimes you get stuck right you may
have two things which are very close to
each other you jump back and forth this
is like having a broken remnants patch
owner on a vinyl record right skip back
over there so in some sense the
mechanism here is exactly the same
mechanism that that particular bird had
it had very seams and it combined them
right and you can change you can change
the how many repetitions how you want to
do it and so on so variation on the
theme are very easy okay on this
particular network of a little song
let's have little intervals of music and
how they are collecting how they are
similar to each other and we want the
thing to sound good so we only move from
something to something that looks like
it right and so this why this sound is
really good and this is actually the
main in some ways of the main thing
about it so let me show you something
else you you see so this is another
process so what I've told you I've
showed you is how by doing this sort of
random moving from one location to
another by sort of tossing a coin a
according to some recipes that we may
have you can create a lot of variability
okay now I'm going to do something a
little bit different and maybe more
interesting which is I have all those
little forms here and I would like to
fit a shape to it
watch what would be is in that a natural
shape that has those little forms as the
air as its boundary okay and what I'm
going to do is again do this process of
what is called diffusion or sort of
random walk on the data what happens
okay so somehow in my mind's eye in my
mathematicians mind that I you see I
could very nicely fill in the gaps fill
in the rest and so on and what I'll do
is show you a really how how this is
done why this is a really natural
process of sort of filling in gaps
connecting connecting the dots so to
speak okay by allowing one to do that
you can see again it's actually quite
remarkable by the way this is all done
by machine there's nothing to do there's
no anything okay here's another network
which is again one of the it was a
project analyzed by students in my my
class this is a romantic network of high
school kids in Jefferson High some some
time ago and the reason they they
actually design build this network so
this is male is is blue and female is
and every every dot here is one student
in the high school and as you can see
there's some big component which is
which is completely connected in other
words everybody is connected to
everybody who has had some romantic
involvement in this particular things if
you change a little chains and new
pieces here and there the interesting so
what is it that you can okay so what are
the conclusions you can reach what they
wanted to know is that somebody is
infected with some some sexually
transmitted disease or some whatever
disease is and you want to know what is
a you want to sort of have a risk
estimate and who is going to be infected
okay now you realize of course it makes
no sense those romantic relations are
staggered in time and you don't have
transitioned backwards in time
but let's pretend that this is not a
romantic thing but this is basically
some collection of nodes and they can
infect each other okay in some way so
it's clear that everybody in that
particular big no Joseph let's a group
of acquaintances somebody is infected
you need to track everybody else who
could be infected and so and you decide
that the risk you could you could do it
in a in a very specific way by actually
measuring how many contacts do people
have and so on to decide whether the
risk is high or not but let's not worry
about it
but the this the students in the class
discovered is that if they wanted to if
they thought that if you think that this
network is random in the sense that
people somehow know each other or become
friends sort of randomly then you are
completely wrong okay this is a very
this network has a very special
structure to it since it's a romantic
relationship network the certain taboos
some things which are not allowed and
once your which means two males and two
two girls was a boyfriend of the two
girls and the girls were a girlfriend of
the two boys okay and that's true for
everybody and once you do that once you
realize that there is this kind of taboo
in the in the network you rely and you
you generate random networks you all
look like this the social network look
sort of look like like this kind of long
strings be some tentacles coming out of
them so the importance again is it by
sort of understanding what it means to
be that what it means to have a geometry
on some level you can actually reach
deep conclusions in this case about sort
of the social interactions at that
particular high school which by the way
is not necessarily true if you do other
kind of social networks okay so let me
explain a little bit so I'm just
always dealing with the same issue so
now the network is every dot out here
this is think of it as a map of to
vegetation patches okay only the left
one where beers and the are and the
right one where a is or vice so you have
those two patches you ask yourself
suppose that you can have several
questions but one it is a following
support fire a lightning hits be okay
and they fight catches on fire and fire
propagates from the shrub to nearby
shrub to nearby shrub etcetera and as it
propagates the question is who is it can
propagate from B to C off of B to a if
you had two oxen B to a or walk from B
to C by the most direct it'll be roughly
at the same time so you could think that
well B and C are at the same risk well
that's not the case because in reality
for fire to reach C it can take any of
those pass right those it jumps from
shrub to shrub right you can take any
one of those paths and they because SM
so many paths of so many possibilities
of reaching see it's it's quite obvious
that C is at much higher risk than a
because to reach it you have to go
through this bridge of channel over
there as a bottleneck and that's hard
you have to to get to reach first of all
the bunvac then you have to go through
it and then you have to aim and in reach
and reach a so here we are talking about
about that this by the way it doesn't
have to be fire it could be some bug
some infestation right and you ask how
how fast is it going to infect everybody
in the same in the same thing and the
problem is it's clear it's going to
infect the see everybody in the same
lobe much more than the ones are
otherwise okay so
clear that so how far you are doesn't
matter it's at what at what risk you are
that matters okay so what you really
want to have is a risk map of you want
to take this picture and somehow map it
doing other pictures that tells you if
things are close there are at high risk
of infecting each other or affecting
each other if you wish or if they're far
that the low risk of doing that that
clearly not in the picture here so if
you were a fireman or as a CDC right and
try to assess infection risks of
populations you need to organize a
population by and this is exactly what
they are doing by how many how many
links different people have and how are
those links propagating across across a
population where you're actually linking
people by having sort of let's say
immediate contact okay again it depends
on the disease right that's good so the
question is can you actually do that now
what I told you before when we were
looking at the the network of the of the
bird singing I said we could run the
network for a very long time and when
you run it for a very long time there
will be we will find out that the the
song labeled G's that was in there is a
one that occurs almost frequently and
every song has a rank okay which tells
you how how important it is in this in
this business so this rank is some
numerical values that you attach to each
node in this network now there are many
ranks they're usually called
eigenvectors but it doesn't really
matter the point is they're a stable
object on the network and they organize
the network for you so let me show you
how we do how how do they do that so
here this the same example as we had
before except I made it slightly more
complicated the circles are trees and
the crosses are shrubs
and assume again we're doing this fire
and transition between shrubs or shrub
is very fast so you can you can make it
as complicated as simple as you want
again you have the two lobes and you
really want to have a risk map you
really want to display it differently so
here is my display so I attached as I
said that sort of this network gives
rise to those stable configuration take
the top three stable configuration and
display every point of the network as
three numbers so it's in in
three-dimensional space so the dots in
three space which are sort of listed
then it looks sort of like a flat region
and then with a point there so every dot
is one of those shrubs or trees the
color just represented being North
ourselves and you see what happened is
in this display how far the dots out are
really represent the risk of one dot F
acting another so if they're far away
they're very they're not susceptible to
each other if they're very close they're
at risk okay of being immediately
infected or a burn or whatever it is
that the relationship between nodes is
so in this map you see first of all the
two lobes have been separated they're
not really they're very weakly affecting
each other but what's happening on the
left and what's happening on the right
is not the same as a North and South on
the left lobe are very close to each
other on the right they're not so let me
return and explain that and the fact
that you can do that it's in some ways
is an amazing fact so here at this point
I mean the trees and the shrubs are
distributed more as randomly or just put
in the same random structure here and
there I'm saying there's a big
difference with the right okay
the big difference is that in this
system shrubs propagate infect each
other faster or propagate fire faster on
the left side there's a trail of shrubs
that goes from north to south so if
something hits the north it'll
immediately propagate to the south on
the right such
trail is not is not present it's sort of
random it doesn't propagate any faster
than it would as if it were beautiful
you want you to you can't see it I mean
I mean if you do statistic you don't see
anything right it's the same statistics
left and right you don't see anything
you can't it doesn't matter there's some
occasional Fisher Fisher's or if you
pass on the left a present that you
actually see by actually looking at the
preponderance of all possible
connections and displaying this in this
this picture that I have there and it
tells us immediately firemen and
somebody gave me that I will immediately
go and sort of cut some stuff on the
left side and not worry about the right
side something which is has been in some
ways the the secret of the power of
mathematics over the last 400 years
which was that new to you you may have
heard of newton and leibniz they sort of
showed that you can use calculus and try
to model the real world around you using
calculus so it looks like a very
complicated saying but basically if you
know small changes of objects you can
aggregate them to get how they evolve on
the long term this is exactly like
calculus all I know is what a relation
is between one shrub and the nearby
shrubs a shrub and the nearby shrubs and
the tree what I got out of it the
picture I showed you gave you the full
picture of the whole universe right
telling you those two regions don't talk
to each other and in that region north
and south are much closer to each other
than you would expect because there's a
string of connections in there so it
does exactly the same thing that
calculus is doing by the way one can
show that anything you do in calculus
you could do by this kind of method if
you want to do and it's so generalize it
is to a point that you can study
practically anything okay what I'm
saying is you can study document you can
study people you can study political
influence and so on
so let me since we have this
to pretend that I'm be okay and I need
to know and I need to evaluate my
political influence okay so actually
forget about a moment suppose I am I
want to know how close how important I
am in the political sphere so I could do
something very simple see do I know
anybody who knows Obama maybe I know him
personally well then I must be an
important person but this is ridiculous
because just being close to anything on
the other hand suppose I were doing the
following thing I would actually look
through my social network and send a
message to Obama to all of my friend and
they will send it further and they will
send it further and with the intention
of passing it on to Obama right now if I
have a lot of tasks that will bring me
there I am quite well much more likely
to actually get the message through okay
I mean a lot of short pass is very good
if I'm right there at fine but otherwise
so in other words I cannot measure my
importance
just by looking how close I am I have to
measure it by all possible connections I
have in my system that's exactly what's
happening here
so here it's the infection power right
so B has a lot of so B has a lot more
infection power overseas and over a
right and and so so what I'm saying
this ability to to do this is is is
critical now you realize that I could do
it mathematically
oh wait by generating all possible past
and count how many times I reach C so I
don't need to know any any any
mathematics I could also do it by
computing something okay so I know this
is called a Monte Carlo method in other
words I toss a coin so I'm at B and now
I toss the coin who are who among my
neighbors I'm going to go to and then
toss a coin again who among my neighbors
I'm going to go
- it'll generate this broken line and I
generate an broken line for each point
intere I will count okay so what I'm
saying is count and toss a coin okay
that's all that happens in order to know
what is the risk of reaching I mean what
is the the probability fish what a
percentage of the time out of all
possible paths of certain lengths I will
reach see and that will tell me quite a
bit about my relation to see it's just
like I said like I could broadcast
messages and see what happens okay but
then I have to look at all possible
paths of all possible messages now the
beauty is that you can do it on the
computer instantaneously okay there are
mathematical ways of doing it which is
basically finding eigenvectors of
matrices and it's just a calculator you
click you get okay
but the point is you you'll get it
very very very simply so now let's go
one step further suppose I want to
lip-read okay so how am I going to
lip-read okay what I could do is
organize the network of the
configuration of my lips okay so in a
given shape if the lips are in a given
shape maybe they relate to a certain
sound that I'm actually think so you see
here are the network you know you think
you took we took a video of somebody say
counting on 1 2 3 4 5 6 etc and we we
have all those pictures and then we
created the network of the pictures okay
so how does one create a network of the
pictures you say well I'm going to lick
to put links to pictures to each other
if they're practically the same okay so
in other words I'm going to the two
pictures and if their practice is the
same with some threshold I will say yes
they are linked so I took this we took a
video we built in
okay and then we asked ourselves again
what we did the same representation one
of the stable distribution of that and
we got the game like I showed you before
and explained points which each points
represent one picture like that and we
find that if you can organize them into
regions and the regions corresponds to
actually various shapes of of the lips
you see the mouse is all open its
basically measures how far it's open
this way or that way I could have done
it directly people can do it directly
but the point is this was no human
intervention there was a recording of
that there was also an audio recording
Basin next to it but that's a different
story
and then automatically you organize the
set of images okay by the way nowadays
this is this is quite basic when you
this kind of thing you want to do if you
want to have your all heard about say
the self-driving car of Google right or
you heard well it turns out that cars
like this neck are coming on the market
within two years three years and you can
you can actually and so the issue what's
the point the point is that somehow the
camera has to understand what it's
looking at right in other words you have
it you have lots of cameras around the
car and they are seeing the road they
need to know if you are in the middle of
the road if you are if you're going to
hit the side if there are obstacles you
need to know if somebody's jumping in
front of you that you have to hit the
brakes all of those things have to be
recognized with machine so how do you
have the Machine actually recognize
anything okay so it's usually done by
taking by running enormous amounts of
data and building groups of of
configurations which are very close to
each other in some way in a way that
matters I'm so not saying this is sort
of a baby example of trying to do that
right here I want to to basically be
able to lip-read so what did I do I took
the images I converted them
image to a dot now say a word
like say so every region that says a
yellowed and so on a different region I
can think of them as there are no songs
of the bird and when I'm saying a word
I'm moving from one region to the next
region to the next region to another
region and different words are different
different trajectories different songs
in there
okay the language by itself has its own
characteristic if I'm talking in French
or in English they the actual if I were
and I and I were to tape somebody doing
it there will be different statistics
but okay so one can use it to actually
build a lip-reader
okay okay well it's quite rudimentary
but it's okay so we discussed about
about contagion and so on that I'm not
going to do that let's change topics
so this is a network of julius caesar so
i don't know how many read Julius Caesar
by Shakespeare but anyway it's a story
about a conspiracy to assassinate julius
caesar the main conspirator is Brutus
and the network that you built among the
actors is following you linked to actors
in this play if they follow each other
okay so you count how many times they
follow each other and that's sort of set
the strength of the link right so that
you've you know this network has this
sort of so the linkage is basically
measured strength of linkage measures
the the probabilities that a certain
actor will follow another actor so if I
link Brutus juice usually see there what
the strengths of that links will tell
you what is the probability that how
many times out of the whole play one
followed the other once you have that
you can ask who is the most important
who has the highest rank in this
so the highest-ranked is Brutus
substantially bigger than Anthony caches
in Caesars there are all conspirators in
this Caesar is not he's effective right
but so here this is very simple and all
it did is showed you something which is
not particularly surprising you do it
for Hamlet it's a little bit more spread
out here is Mac Macbeth and this is
described a little bit nicer this is a
better display the most important
character is in the middle there and the
size of the nodes is by the rank in the
in this system okay now let's see this
is actually quite a bit more interesting
so see another project so what I'm
showing you is basically stuff coming
out of projects of students in my class
so this project is they the students
were really interested by French
literature and most of them by the way
totally allergic to mathematics and it's
completely changed in some ways so they
they wanted to build the network of
characters in the comedy men which is a
body of of work of Balzac Balzac as you
can see I'm sorry lived in 1800 and so
he say here it's one of the founders of
the realist North novel it's the the
work that we are talking about is an
interconnected collection of novels and
short stories and basically describing
life in France during that period so
there is one character in in his work so
this is a I mean they thought that
there's one per character
oh I'm sorry this is it should it's not
supposed to talk okay
we are in the same story all in the same
in the same book the strengths of the
obsession is the same as I said with
Joseph ship Caesar and there are 30
characters there's one character who is
Eugene no arsenic which is a very
go-getter character that appears quite a
bit in the energy everybody thought he
is the main hero of his work he should
be the most important character in
everything it just like in Judas is er
Brutus was clearly the main conspirator
so that was clear so that was the
expectation when they actually put in
the network in fact if you look at the
network the the page rank as you can see
this character that they thought would
be principal is actually not a principal
and the interesting should the
interesting part is this doesn't go
backwards okay
okay the interesting part is that the
characters who are the most important
one were sleazy bankers okay so nothing
has changed and the sleazy bankers
actually throw the one in the middle
they are sleazy bankers Eugene the
rafting yak is out there
those are bankers okay one of them was
Nate is sort of modeled after James
rotschild at the time but Baltic was
very much concerned with the influence
of the financiers and finance on the
structure of society at the time and so
they felt he in his work he was
basically displaying the fact that they
were essentially interact basically
affecting everybody's life and are
connected to everybody in a very strong
sense and this is really what came out
of this it's not the fact that they are
socially connected and they are
basically leading and affecting society
that at least that was his point of view
and it comes out very clearly when you
actually look at the at this particular
networks yeah other thing in there which
are interesting for example when you
look at the various women so the women
in the nobility did not are they honest
women as they used to call them we're
much more marginal than the actual
prostitutes and there is other women
because of their interaction with
various people so you have to understand
that building such a network is is by
itself designed to lead to certain
conclusion so how you build the network
will give give rise to different
conclusions so like everything it's a
basic you shouldn't trust it okay but
the point is it does give you a global
view of all the local tidbits that you
have in terms of connection as people in
the various stories and it gives you a
map
of everything here this is another
example where the network gives you this
kind of insight and that here it's it's
actually a network of people in a karate
club and as you can see the network is
sort of split into two groups the
highest-ranked
characters in there and what happened is
a short time later they actually
completely splintered into to karate
clubs to separate karate clubs okay so
you could have seen that this would
happen or might happen because one and
34 are not connected so there are two
characters who really local leaders if
you wish of the club but they themselves
barely interact okay and so you could
have say you could have seen a predicted
a possible splinter in in that system
okay I was actually going to give you a
lecture on mathematics but I'm not going
to do that I'm just going to say we see
this in everyday so here are the
networks that you are familiar with
right every day and it says there are
three conditions of the day rainy cloudy
and sunny and at the given state at the
given position place let's say we're
looking at zero for example and if it's
rainy it has a certain 30 percent of the
time is going to stay rainy the next day
and one-third of the time is going to
convert to cloudy and one-third of the
time to sunny you're understandably by
tossing the three sided coin right a lot
of time and then count right or just do
global statistics or do a little bit of
mathematics which is write down a
description of that network and ask what
is a stable state of it and you
immediately get this